[Music]
why did you want to come out and support
these other teenagers so many reasons um
we did is just such an amazing thing a
cause it's just it's so beautiful so
just it's so cool to see all these kids
that are coming together to change the
world you know and you are such a
supportive person we saw that you posted
spending some luck to Abby Lee Miller as
you talked to her how is she I visited
her yesterday I actually went down to
the hospital to see her she's not good
but she luckily is in good spirits so
she doesn't she's not 100% on what's
going on right now which is not really
the bad thing she's in definitely in
good spirits but it's so hard when you
see what's going on it's so so
heartbreaking
I mean why when you say heartbreaking
and she's not good tell us what exactly
is going on and how is she you know um
she is very sick she's very ill I don't
know if it's officially announced red
she has I don't know if she's keeping
that private or not um but what she has
is a very bad thing and you don't want
anyone to go through it I was just
telling her I was like people do see her
as the big scary lady who yells at kids
on TV but it's not true and she is a
person first of all and she is loving
she's caring she taught me so many
things I'm so grateful for that it's so
hard to see her go through that and
being sad and just laying there and
trying to cry but physically not being
able to
it shows Wyatt why can't she can't she
just kind of like she would start to cry
she'd be like there's you just stop